the UK could become home to the world's
first power station to use a power nee
and new technology a government
Commission study has come out in support
of plans from the goons which can
harness tidal power the technology
involves a coastal defense structure
known as a breakwater with turbines that
would use the rise and fall of water to
create energy the guinea-pig would be
Swansea Bay where a 1.3 billion pound a
goon has been proposed despite the cost
proponents say the low-carbon method
provides security as it depends on the
reliable urban flow of the tide will
Charles Henry's a former energy minister
and the man behind the recommendation so
Charles this doesn't look terribly good
value for taxpayers does it I mean
you're looking for a guarantee of 90
years for the taxpayers to pay 120
megawatts put pans per megawatt hour I
mean that's even more expensive than
Hinkley Point
well those figures are well out of date
here and and what I've been proposing is
that we should look at the subsidy cost
over the lifetime of the project and if
you do that because a lagoon lasts for
120 years you can't compare it with a
project which has lasts for 30 or 60
years and if you compare it in that way
then actually the cost is very
competitive between lagoons between
nuclear and offshore wind so it's I
think it is not just good for security
of supply and decarbonization and jobs
but it's also a good deal for consumers
so sorry - how long would these
guarantees from the taxpayers lost this
promise to buy energy at a fixed price
well the there had been a proposal for
90 years I said that is too long and
I've said that 60 years strikes me as
better that's half the project compared
to two-thirds of the lifetime of a
nuclear plant or two-thirds of the
lifetime of an offshore wind farm and
but I think by doing that it's a more
realistic ambition it doesn't have a
huge amount of impact on the cost of it
in terms of pushing the costs up and I
think that by doing it in this way that
we end up bringing in the investment
which we need and doing it in a way that
is affordable to consumers at the end of
the day Swansea as a Swansea trying to
do good cost
30p per household per year
for 30 years there was a very small
amount of money to kickstart an industry
but even 60 years though Charles our
that's an awful long period of time I
mean is it possible that the technology
could get overtaken by new alternatives
in that time oh of course there's always
new technologies coming forward but we
can't make a decision now on
technologies we don't yet know about
there are some which are very promising
but they haven't yet been commercialized
and therefore we have to make an
assumption about what is the right
decisions for this country now so I
think that one which really is good for
security of supply because of the
absolute predictability of the times
something which is very good for the
decarbonisation as one of the lowest
carbon emitters of any source of power
generation which will create thousands
of jobs in a new industry and can due to
certain affordable rate for consumers I
think that is a good decision for the UK
at this time of course there may be
other technologies which come through in
due course but for the time being I
think actually we've got a very good
opportunity which we should seize now
you talk about the predictability of the
tides but I mean the predictability the
costs of the Swansea project or anything
but I mean the the expected budget has
risen from about 900 million to 1.3
billion in less than two years well
we've all seen as projects go through
the process of being assessed and
examined then they get the cost often go
up we've seen that with nuclear power
we've seen it with so many other things
that the government ultimately will do
this negotiation the government will say
we think this is a reasonable price to
pay and that they will then fix that
contract for different strike price as
it's called with the power company but I
think that this is something which is
the time has come for it we've been
looking for decades at the tides and
thinking how can we harness those there
is a technology which we can use to do
that it would put the UK at the
forefront of that we would be leading
this new industry there'll be
opportunities around the world which we
could benefit from as well so it's not
just about energy it's about couple of
defenses it's about economic
regeneration it's an auto a well rounded
package of benefits but it's the
technology genuinely exportable I mean
not every country around the world is
going to be able to use tidal lagoon
power
I mean how confident are you that
there's a market for this stuff out
there I'm confident that there's a
reasonable market you're absolutely
right you've got to have a good title
range in order button to be able to
benefit and we know that countries like
India
France China Korea a country where
they've got great opportunities for this
now they will do much of their own
manufacturing but a lot of the service
work a lot of the environmental
consenting work a lot of the project
management work would be run from from
Britain because of where the Pioneers
just as we've seen with offshore wind
we're in a very strong position to then
lead the world in taking that technology
forward I don't think we'll see the same
cost Falls as we've seen in offshore
wind but we can certainly see this as a
technology where the UK can win and is
good for the economy it's good for the
environment and is good for consumers